hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
earlier this year with the google play
edition devices there is a little bit of
worry that we might not see a new nexus
every year but this is 2013 and we know
by now that just about everything new is
going to leak before it's announced and
this new nexus is no exception so
without any further ado this is
everything we know about the next nexus
so first of all the rumor mill really
got going when an android 4.4 promo
video from google went up and had a one
or two second clip in it of a google
employee holding an unannounced device
that said nexus on it so we all pretty
much assume that that's the next nexus
right there he's got an early copy and
essentially that's where a lot of our
initial impressions of what it's going
to look like came from since then though
we've gotten way more leaks from fcc
submissions and leaked service manuals
and actual photos of the device itself
that give us a much better idea of what
to expect when the actual device is
released so we basically already know
what it's going to look like at this
point so here is a pretty accurate
render i would say of what to expect
when the announcement finally rolls
around when we see that nexus 5 for the
first time you can pretty much assume
that that's what it's going to look like
has a larger display and the led
notification light on the front a larger
camera aperture on the back the matte
black finish similar to the current
nexus 7 it's a very simple clean pretty
much understated device now i have the
nexus 4 here which is also in its day a
very clean simple understated device
because it's a nexus it has no front
buttons on the front but on the back it
at least had a little bit of shine a
little bit of glitz or something to
significantly distinguish it from other
devices out there but from what we've
seen of this new nexus it looks to
actually be even more of a clean simple
understated device now two things um
will this actually be called nexus 5 and
will this actually be called android 4.4
kitkat well about the kitkat thing you
can pretty much be guaranteed that yes
it's going to be called kitkat some
people still don't believe it but uh if
you've read more into the android 4.4
story you'll realize that the
partnership with kitkat came essentially
at like the last second it was a very
last second for fun sort of deal so
earlier league versions of android still
show some key lime pie elements and some
naming schemes from key lime pie and
even a debug icon from key lime pie but
they've probably going to change all
these things to match up with the kitkat
mantra as far as the nexus 5 name goes
it's kind of hard to say because on one
hand they could say it's the nexus 5 but
then the next nexus will be the nexus 6
and then the nexus 7 which is the new
tablet
so naturally based on that a lot of
people said it's just going to be called
the nexus 4 2013 or the new nexus 4.
that makes sense but honestly the only
thing that's actually confirmed right
now is the model number which is the lg
g820
and that confirms two things number one
it'll be made by lg again and number two
it'll be a natural step up from the
model number from the lg g2 which was
the lg d802 but for the purposes of this
video and for the purpose of the rumors
we're just going to call it the nexus 5.
so if this new device is based on the lg
g2 should we expect it to have high-end
specs like the lg g2 that's a question
that's interesting because well first of
all the nexus line started off as being
known for high-end specs the nexus one
was the first device to have a one
gigahertz processor which at the time
was nuts uh but right now as of more
recently the nexus four comes out and uh
goes with a more mid high-end range spec
sheet but a much more competitive price
so we've actually gotten the leaked
specs of the new nexus and we can
confirm just about everything here so
it's going to have a 5-inch 1080p
display it's going to have that qualcomm
snapdragon 800 quad-core processor
clocked at 2.3 gigahertz it'll have 2
gigabytes of ram and an 8 megapixel back
facing camera with optical image
stabilization it'll also have a sealed 2
300 milliamp hour battery if you were
looking for a removable battery or
removable storage nexus is not for you
and we're also looking at connectivity
on lte bands in the united states and
it'll all come in a package that's just
8.6 millimeters thick these are all
pretty high to mid to high specs i mean
they're not note 3 future proof sort of
specs on a phone but they're also
pretty decent specs and i would expect
to see a phone based off of the six to
seven hundred dollar lg g2 in the google
play store as competitive as google can
get i wouldn't be surprised to see a 16
or 32 gigabyte version of the nexus 5
sell for 4.99 off contract in the play
store as far as carriers in the united
states since the play store tends to be
a very united states centric thing
i would expect all the major ones but
don't cross your fingers for a verizon
nexus 5. just don't it's probably not
going to happen and even if it does
happen again uh verizon's likely going
to find a way to screw it up like it
does with all its other promising
devices on its network so i'm actually
already in the process of fully
switching over to a t in order to just
use a t as my main line right now either
way all the information about nexus 5
will be finally unveiled and released
officially this month it's october along
with a whole bunch of other awesome tech
this month but all of the rumors will
finally cease and the false things will
be dispelled when the google event
actually happens i have a feeling that's
not going to be the biggest surprise at
the event the more exciting things that
we don't already know much about like
the asus built nexus 10 or maybe some
google glass or some google chrome news
might be more exciting but either way
follow me on twitter for more of the uh
nexus 5 coverage as it unrolls and if we
get more stuff i'll be sure to share it
with you if we get more leaked stuff
that we don't already know i'll be
tweeting that out but either way that's
been it thank you for watching and i
will talk to you guys in the next video
peace
you